guys you asked for it for so long we
finally got it merch is on sale right
now uh we really talk about it but i
want to start pushing it because we have
a really cool designs that joe and i
made up ourselves and it's the limited
run so whatever is on sale now the
second it's sold out it's not coming
back it's available right now uh in the
links on these videos or at our website
savilcanocomedy.com joederosainfo.com
that's tastebuds merch i also have solo
merch
up there as well
and so check all of it out and uh
and and buy some merch tweeted us the
merch and we will retweet you or repost
you on instagram we want to see which
ones you guys are liking and we want to
see the merch out in the wild really
cool project that we put together so to
see it out there
is going to be cool so check out
our merch for perch guys i'm on the road
and i hope you come see me let me tell
you where i'm going to be very soon all
tickets on sale right now at
savolcanocomedy.com
october i'm in hamilton and toronto uh
richmond virginia and hershey
pennsylvania uh in november i'm in
knoxville i'm in atlanta i'm in
birmingham i'm in louisville and i'm in
evansville indiana uh and in december i
am in jacksonville tampa florida orlando
florida sacramento san jose and santa
rosa california that rounds out my 2022
of touring everything's on sale right
now we added second shows in hershey we
had second shows in toronto we had
second shows in
atlanta and tampa so thank you guys so
much everybody else i hope you see out
there
coming up next october we got dead crow
comedy club in north carolina
in november i'll be going to michigan do
a bunch of shows and i've got tons of
other stuff around that stuff and after
that stuff and coming up in the new year
and all that anyway you can find all of
it at jonarosainfo.com
also if you're in new york city please
come to my bar in sandwich shop joey
roses uh all info for there is joey
rose's
joeyrosesnyc.com
we're open
six days a week
opening at 12 p.m every day great
sandwiches awesome hang
and lots of booze
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
all right so if you're done with that
can i actually take the straw out of it
it's really bad yeah yeah i hate it i
have ocd i thought you were
sideways uh no no like like not pointing
at me i want you to should i put this on
you take all this in take all right
[Laughter]
just not so it's not pointing at me yes
i don't want to see it yeah oh you're
like like it's a fear of straws
or like uneasiness with straws that's
straw is there anything pointing at me
really it has like a pointy edge kind of
yeah
wow okay okay interesting
please tell me you're taping this
all right
what about what about yours welcome back
to the
tastebuds podcast i'm glad you just got
a glimpse of the insanity that i'm
dealing with
yeah i'm the insane one the straw
couldn't be pointing at him
i'm the insane
[Laughter]
that's the [ __ ] that
[Laughter]
it's terrible maybe it's like some weird
italian thing it's like a not what they
call it the uh the malarka yeah
i say that i actually have said that i
said cause two things happened to me
that and also this is a weird thing that
no one really understands but it's true
and i don't know how it's true but it's
true and it happens every
single day since i noticed it years ago
and you're not going to believe me
but
every day
at some point when i go to take a drink
of something a little bit spills on me
every day
it happens and i'm at the point where i
got to the point where i was like
noticed it then i noticed it keep
happening like that's so funny then it
kept happening and i was like
this is this is not this doesn't feel
like it's real and it kept happening and
it's unbeknown like i don't
and then i was like i think someone put
like a light curse on me like like a
like a oh almost like like an ironic
like an ironic curse where you're like
you're not gonna use a straw take that
yeah
some people call it a curse other people
say you're a slob
women can we can we have a psychic on
and see if you're cursed is that who
christ
you should stage your saves the place
and do all that stuff people do i don't
know i it happened yesterday has it
happened today yet no but it will i know
i i believe you because i watched
surviving death the show on netflix and
now i think i believe in reincarnation
yeah it's insane i watched some of that
show too because i'm so i'm so scared of
dying
are you too bro it kind of
people around me me everything i think
at the moment it's gonna happen when's
it gonna be how's it gonna go yes i
think of your everyone's death i think
of my own death i lay in bed thinking
about death i literally
feel like i'm going to bring it upon
myself because i i get so anxious and
tense and i can't stop thinking about it
it's like my brain is like looping about
that stuff and i'll think of something
else to distract myself and then all of
a sudden it goes back to that no i do it
too i do it
by the way before i say this we batch
recorded so when i say i'm hungover it's
still from three months
but other times when it was three weeks
the odds are looks like the odds of him
spilling on himself as you being
hungover
[Laughter]
hey our good friend great comics sean
donnelly everybody joining us today uh
sean welcome to the show thank you for
having me i i worry about it with with
like being hung over i'm like like even
like right now i'm like
i'm hungover what if i would have died
in my sleep because like i was
dehydrated and i haven't had too fast or
i had a heart attack while i was
sleeping i think about that i take my
blood pressure about three times a day i
got two different machines upstairs so i
can compare their accuracies i have
phenomenal blood pressure really
phenomenal that's wonderful you know wow
i'm on medication
i have phenomenal blood pressure my
blood work is my favorite good but but
uh knock on wood and said it done again
i i'm i'm afraid i have i have a wrist
machine and an arm machine i take it
twice a day i take each one at least
twice a day sometimes these aren't
terribly accurate i wouldn't trust well
i entered today
to the pods we just filmed i'm going to
go upstairs it's going to be through the
roof
are you serious yeah blood pressure goes
up from this yes
i heard you guys through the door not
like me from this but when you start
yelling and get that active it goes up
oh well okay my body can't recognize
real tension versus our attention
you don't mean you're walking upstairs
with anxiety because you used to make
fun of me for that no not anxiety but my
blood pressure will be high okay i'm
screaming and yelling at you you're
getting pissed off that would that
worries me that that happens yeah
actually i guess this is not good for my
health this podcast
you ever think this you ever get worried
that you have candy stones and then like
me and you drink like and you realize if
you drink a bunch you have less of a
chance of getting kidney stones because
like burns them out yeah yeah yeah and
like like i guess the acid from from the
woods but you're also burning out your
liver
being frequently yelled at changes the
mind brain and body in a multitude of
ways including increasing the activity
of the
amygdala amygdala
increasing stress hormones in the
bloodstream increasing muscular
attention and more oh
yeah dude oh yeah i this is not good for
me yeah although this groundbreaking
scientific study
you know uh
increases uh your blood pressure yeah
you know who did this study your heart
people that did the pepsi challenge
the uh oh so you heard us yelling
outside yeah and when i came in so sean
got here and came to the door did you
ring the bell i did the bell doesn't
work i was outside for about 10 minutes
listening to you guys screaming at each
other at the top of your lungs and i
said you sound like a gay couple having
the worst domestic violence fight ever
just talking about coke versus pepsi but
the cops are trying to be like what is
the point of this great have you heard
like glass breaking
it's funny what it leaps out of on the
on the pod because
that's what that was one of the episodes
when we started i was like man this is
going to be like just so tame yeah like
we're just talking about soda like who
cares and then like then he starts one
in his dumb mouth
and he has completely illogical stuff to
say yeah it's all
and we just the audio just sounds like
there's a fight going on police sirens
but you said just dropping audio the cap
show up dude like the cameras were
turned off but the mic stayed on
that's very funny like joe is there a
safe place you can go
[Laughter]
sean was like joe was like the kid that
didn't want to interrupt his parents
fighting
he just texted me i'm at the door
guys is it my fault
you said you um uh you heard us yelling
about presidents yeah in the mixture of
the coke i heard the coke the
president's thing was because xiao kept
saka fighting the pepsi challenge as if
it was the emancipation process
i was saying in a country where a
presidential election could conceivably
be stolen we're gonna trust the results
of the pepsi challenge
which i think is a fair point
the pepsi challenge was like i can't
believe you come on we're out of the
episode you can't give me that much oh
i'll give you that but i i don't i i
think the pepsi challenge is a excellent
excellent argument i think it trumps
anything at this point they say it was
an excellent
it's a great thing to bring up said that
it was bogus i said that
why are we listening to the results of
it because it's not a marketing campaign
it's not just funny it's funny it's not
because they lost the pepsi if they lost
the pepsi challenge would they have put
it in the marketing campaign no no thank
you that's the campaign
they can't they keep because it's their
campaign yeah it's gotta be that would
you think they were gonna put that i
guarantee you i guarantee you in order
to do that and say that and have that
campaign they had to have an independent
auditor there
to verify those results you might not be
right guarantee it's like quiz show but
they could not start an ad campaign
saying that they beat them in a taste
test without having independence you
really think that pepsi went out there
willy-nilly and said we're going to let
it fly however it flies and if we lose
this thing it's already on tv but they
won there's nothing we can do
why do you think they want what they
want
they didn't win because they they
smudged the numbers i'm telling you you
cannot you could not that that would be
a legal problem they have to have an
independent auditor there so you could
go out cooper's and libra you could go
out to ten people procter and get away
and seven of them say i like the pepsi
better and you go that's the pepsi
challenge there you go they said they
did it all across the country right but
you get my point but they but joe my
point is that that's not what they did
all statistics are doctored all
statistics ever ever ever that's why
it's true it's true
that's why michael moore gets so much
[ __ ] about the statistics in his movies
and that's why every statistical poll is
not trusted statistics are not
trustworthy
and i'll say it again the statistics on
gun violence we're going to believe the
pepsi challenge what about what about
this are we talking about what about the
statistics that i'm whipping your ass
in taste buds that's fine but that's an
accurate statistic
because there's vote there's hard votes
right that we have recorded you just
said all statistics ever ever ever are
doctored
well no he's saying advertising is
doctored
here's the thing he's right though if
they did it as a contest almost like the
remember they make millions you watch
the mcmillions documentary if they did
it as a contest he's right and they they
cheated you know somebody they they'd be
they'd be screwed but he's saying as an
ad campaign just google our statistics
trustworthy pimp just move it just
google it
before i jump
why don't we host the pepsi challenge of
joey roses while he's in ronald mcdonald
pimp i literally can't here you go i
can't there
shut the [ __ ] up you dope shut up joe
shut up joe
shut up you know what you're afraid
perhaps he's gonna win while you're
standing there i was dressed as a dumb
clown how many other things do i got to
do because this num nuts
picks the easy win food every time
except the worst challenge he get you i
just picked pepsi over coke
[Applause]
you this dope thinks i can't walk in
there with a true leader did you see the
way
this son of a [ __ ] lit up when you go
uh we're doing mayo uh because he's got
cream cheese saying i have mayo and you
and he thought for a second you left i
messed up and i said you like cream
cheese more than mayo did you see the
way he lit up why would he like some
easy win why would i not
light up just no so i didn't light up
when he said it the other way oh you
lied
no you didn't today you'd be allowed for
no sake what do you mean i'm not being
laughed you're not making any good
points joe what are you talking about
you're just yelling into a void bro what
are you talking about it's it's getting
sad for me
it's getting sad you're devolving you're
devolving you're infuriating you're
infuriating you're infuriating
you're in your scream into the void you
mean you say nothing i really want to
talk about they're saying nothing
you have not matured
[Laughter]
i mean it was fine when gatto got in my
ass and was screaming at me that was all
fun engaging well he was making great
points oh shut up
you know the craziest michael moore
thing to bring it back to what you said
is that he got the interview with roger
uh from roger and me did you know that
what do you mean
you ever see roger me about with the gm
guy i forget it was a lot i remember the
first one he did it made him famous he
was trying to track that it was during
the the auto thing when they were moving
to mexico and it was a big deal and it's
what made michael more famous and the
whole idea is that he's chasing this guy
roger smith around the country to get
this interview with him to be like the
people of detroit need you what are you
doing and they make it look like he
keeps missing him and they're avoiding
him and they're pushing him off and in
reality he got the he interviewed the
guy and they just made the movie that he
never got it no
this is what i mean you're right you're
right you know what you're absolutely
right we should take the roger and more
documentary by michael moore and we
should use that to prove that the pepsi
challenge wasn't accurate
now you're right i'm sorry i'm sorry
michael board the guy that won the oscar
for best documentary documentary
right documentary that must be on film
that must be in the past the challenge
was not real it must mean it he's saying
it's all fixed that's what that's what
joe's saying i actually agree
of course you're gonna say it's fixed
you got lost you lost by a major margin
all right let's get into this we asked
sean today what are some foods you like
what are some foods you don't like in
his list of foods that he didn't like
sean wrote to us he does not like
mayonnaise and he does not like cream
cheese
interesting i think those are both
polarizing i think people either like
them or don't like them so we thought it
was a good matchup i happen to love
cream cheese joe happens to really love
mayo so instead of saying what do you
like more mayo or cream cheese because
so many people dislike both of them
today we're battling what's worse
mayo or cream cheese i'm gonna battle
that mayo is worse and that i like cream
cheese he's gonna battle that cream
cheese is worse and he likes mayo you're
gonna be in the middle because you
dislike both and color commentate
however you like okay mediate however
you like okay yell if you like don't
yell make points anything you want to do
it's a free-for-all
all right and am i am i picking the
winner at the end like are you guys
going to convince me what's worse you
can give your take on who you think won
yeah but then we'll go to the actual
poll okay okay with the votes okay
sounds good all right we're gonna get
into it yeah i i need a i need an i love
you chad i do too
[Laughter]
before we start one is to insult each
other i want us to tell we love each
other because if things are not spicy we
insult each other yeah but if we're
really going off on each other we tone
it down with an i love your channel it
gets too hated
and i did and i will say this uh you
know what i want to add a new thing to
the i love you chant
what
you know how
so when we do it's time to get salty
that's the chant we say it three times
then we launch immediately into an
insult
as soon as you've done the chat i want
to do that the opposite with no matter
what happens i love you where we shoot
each other oh that's nice that's a good
idea it makes sense
yeah
uh i'm really in this position though
yeah oh man
you guys didn't i love you champion i
love you
it took a while
because the couch is uncomfortable okay
ready no matter what happens i love you
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you i truly
missed you and i'm happy to see you
today oh that's so nice
all right well i i don't want to say i
feel the exact same way but you know i
echo those sentiments and i really did
miss you it was a few weeks since i've
seen you which normally is not that long
of a amount of time and i you were often
on my mind
that's beautiful same that was really
nice yeah i yeah i bought that
it was real i know all right i actually
feel better already did you yeah were
you i think honestly i've been saying
sucker
[Laughter]
all right ready here we go time to
b-a-t-t-l-e buds
got
here's the thing
these are both what i like about this
pick is is i do i you saw you disagreed
when we talked about yesterday but i
actually do think that these are both
very very polarizing uh spreads i guess
it's the sure i agree with that um
i think male 1
yeah yeah i actually
i well i might be in the minority here
i find cream cheese equally
uh polarizing like if if cream cheese is
not on a bagel
or cream cheese has any sort of
flavoring in it
i am so [ __ ] put off immediately when
i get sushi if they don't
sometimes it's by surprise cream cheese
and sometimes mayo too
both of those i'm like i'm disgusted i i
get app these are two substances that
have to be on certain things at certain
times in a certain way certain
certain flavor and when they get out of
that zone i find them both revolting
dude one time i ate a chicken sandwich
that had mayo on it i didn't know i ate
half the sandwich realized it had mayo
threw the other half away from the
sandwich yeah that's how much i get
grossed out by mayo but wait a minute
you don't though because you ate the
first half of the sandwich with
marijuana didn't even recognize it i
didn't know i know i didn't recognize it
but once i knew i knew is it appealing
it's mental yeah it's because
something about mayo i i've said this
before on the pot i like mayo in certain
situations just like you said i like it
on a ham and cheese sandwich
i like it
i don't even know where else tell you
the truth
mayo is great on a bologna with tomato
a ham and cheese a turkey and cheese
on a cold cut sandwich in moderation
other than that something about me and
when you look at the ingredients yeah
it's also in like every dip ever
yeah i don't like mayo and dips at all i
don't like it but it's in like ranch
it's in i don't like ranch i have like a
sour cream and onion dip
oh yeah i don't mind that no way that's
kind of isn't that sour cream though
that doesn't have mayo in it
i think it has sour cream and onions you
know what it is i think it is for me i
thought you would cut it with mayonnaise
i have this weird thing in the back of
my head i always assume all mayo has
gone bad all of it don't disagree yeah
it's this weird thing where i'm like i
could curdle it could be a weird almost
like milk because they always say like
oh is that left out too long and mayo
smells weird when it's fresh yes and
even worse when it's not fresh yes i
think mayo it also
miller explains that some people are
extremely grossed out by mayonnaise
because well they find it's consistently
similar to that of white gluttonous
bodily fluids such as
pus semen and fat and therefore won't
touch
the word that was going to come out of
my mouth right now was let's be honest
it does kind of it's too close to that
kind of stuff and i was going to say
ejaculate
yeah i would say pus as well
yeah my gripe with uh cheddar or sorry
uh cream cheese is um
first of all i'm not big on a spreadable
cheese
ever it's not real cheese
it tastes like cheese it's got a cheese
i don't think it's real cheese-ish
flavor
but i don't what i really don't care for
about cream cheese is
it is stiff she's
stiff and spreadable at the same time
which i find very odd
cream cheese has a consistency all its
own it's almost like you're eating clay
like a soft clay or something that's
wild you're from philly
i know i love it on a bagel that's it if
there's too much of it on the bagel
every time i get a bagel with cream
cheese i have to take some off
i can't have enough on a bagel
i don't like that it trumps butter as
the number one thing on a bagel
i think most people think they associate
bagels with cream cheese and i'm like
butter you mean the number one thing in
the world that all french cooking is
based on
are you kidding me i hate the fact that
like ah cream cheese on a bagel not
butter on a bagel's face also you put
butter on more things like english
muffins toast it works across the ground
but
i'll say if i'm in the mood for tuna or
a cold cut sandwich not like salami it
has to either ham or turkey i will have
mayo that's about it i don't love it in
like like if it is a choice to have like
um a lobster roll mayo based or lemon or
oil oil oil based i always want the
lemon or the butter base i should say
not the mayo when when potato salad
macaroni salad when they're swimming in
that mayo i can't stand it i rather have
like an oil-based
potato it's just something about me it's
not good in any form except that one for
me
cream cheese exact opposite but wait
there's not a time that i don't like
cream cheese on something it is besides
on a bagel it is in cheesecake it is in
red velvet icing it is it's
it's yes
no no no no no no no no i was just in my
house
i don't know if you if you said this i
apologize you don't like to you like
tuna fish cream cheese and jelly no i
said i said okay if i'm in the mood if
i'm in the mood for tuna sometimes i
like the italian made tuna because the
mayo is it just but if you haven't used
sparingly wendy's wedding salad that's
it wendy's puts mayo on the bird i won't
eat it i'd say nobody you know no
condiment and i put ketchup on myself
okay i'll say this about mayo i think if
you make your food properly you don't
need mayo i honestly believe that if you
make i'm a big chicken sandwich fan
people like mayo want chicken sandwiches
i gotta be on there if you make your
chicken properly juicy enough you don't
people use it just sean for fundamentals
i want to congratulate you for one of
the dumbest things anybody ever said
and now a word from our sponsor better
help
guys it can be tough to train your brain
to stay in problem solving mode when
faced with a challenge in life that's
all i do i feel like i'm a professional
problem solver before i was a uh the job
i have now which is you know
writing jokes writing television and
problem solving for my entire cast and
show and all that stuff i used to be a
bartender and owned a business and it
was the same thing and it just
you could tell by my tone and look in my
face that
it's just too much
but when you learn how to find your own
solutions there's no feeling better a
therapist can help you become a better
problem solver make it easier for you to
accomplish your goals no matter how big
or small and that is where a better help
comes into play i tell you right now i
go to therapy i encourage therapy i try
to get family and friends at therapy so
if you've never tried it you always
wondered about it this is a real easy
way to start without having to go
somewhere and meet someone in person um
if you're thinking of giving therapy a
try try better help it's great options
convenient it's accessible it's
affordable it's entirely online um get
matched with a therapist to filling out
a brief survey and you can switch
therapists any time and you don't even
have to be seen on the camera but you
can speak to someone and that's where it
all starts so
when you want to become a better problem
solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
tastebuds today to get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com
tastebuds
guys if you are like me then in the
summer
you are hot and when you go to bed
you're hot i have actually a
memory foam mattress that retains heat i
run hot and a lot of times if it's too
warm i sweat through the night i hate it
i have to change my sheets the next day
or if i crank up the ac too much and
it's so cold that i'm buried under the
blankets i sweat anyway so
miracle brand is this new sponsor the
podcast that do sheets that are
self-cooling bed sheets
and you can stay comfortable all night
long it uses silver-infused fabrics made
by nasa
to be temperature regulated bedding
so you can sleep at the perfect
temperature all night long this is
something that you probably know but
maybe you don't think about it but and
this is a crazy fact
bed sheets can harbor more bacteria than
a toilet seat
they could lead to acne allergies and
stuff he knows it's gross actually
miracle brand offers a whole line of
self-cleaning eco-friendly bedding such
as sheets pillowcases comforters that
prevent 99 of bacteria and require
to be laundered three times less
i just got my set in the mail i'm loving
them instantly uh the first night i felt
the difference literally felt cooler the
entire
night they have self-cooling properties
like i mentioned uh they're
self-cleaning
this is crazy this is like a sheet this
is like the revolution
revolutionizing the sheet industry
they're comfortable they're quality and
they're better for your skin go to try
miracle.com tastebuds to try today we've
got a special deal for our listeners
booze
be sure to use our promo code tastebuds
at checkout to save forty percent
for zero percent and get three free
towels who doesn't love a bacteria free
towel and miracle is so confident their
product it's back with a 30 day money
back guarantee if you aren't a hundred
percent satisfied full refund
boom upgrade to sleep with miracle brand
go to try miracle.com taste buds and use
the code taste buds to clean your free
three-piece towel set and save 40 off
again that's try miracle dot com slash
taste buds thank you miracle brand for
sponsoring the episode
how is that done
it's got nothing to do with moist it
adds a flavor it's a flavoring you
actually i don't believe that's true i
know how to cook and and i put mayo on
certain things because it enhances it to
me you don't think some people put
mayonnaise stuff so they get some
but yeah but that i'm not saying people
don't do that i'm saying that's not the
reason you use mayo though i think
that's one of the reasons people use
mayo i'm saying people will dump ketchup
on a well done steak and that's not what
the ketchup is supposed to be used for
can you pull out ingredients
yeah yeah like
can you pull up mayo's ingredients
so this is the thing right i i
for some reason sometimes mel a mayo it
smells gross it could taste gross out of
context and it could even
touch like the feel of it is not good
it's a ticking time bomb yeah but when
you look at it when you
as a matter of fact as a matter of fact
here's the thing i want our listeners to
do right now go to your fridge right now
go to your fridge right now
everyone has mayo in their fridge right
unless you like can even have it for
anything go to the mail turn it i want
in the comments what the expiration date
is of the mayo in your fridge because
nine times out of ten when i go to use
my mayo it is completely expired because
i use it so sparingly and it goes bad so
quick and i'm always like it's always a
game of like all right this mayo has
been done a month this has been done two
weeks
actually i think a lot of what you guys
are saying is wrong mayo according to
this tends to prevent bacterial growth
because it is made with acids it has
vinegar or lemon juice in it mayo
actually has a very long shelf life in
the in the refrigerator now it's not
going to no it's months it's months
months is a long no no no no no i know i
know but i'm compared to ketchup or
mustard i'm sure but this is my point
everyone go right now so today is this
is coming out what somewhere in uh late
late mid mid to late september whatever
date it's gonna
22. go i want to know right now i want
to know the expertise today on all your
mayos let us know and i guarantee you
there'll be a very high contingent that
are expired yeah but yes but you want to
talk sparing use and shelf life cream
cheese is the loser in that argument by
a long shot cream cheese goes bad faster
than mayonnaise does and it's used even
less than mayonnaise's unless you eat
bagels every day
you're using your cream cheese once
every few weeks at the moment
taste of home says that unopened cream
cheese packages last up to one month
past the date printed on the box once
almost once open it should be consumed
in 10 days that's not true either i'll
tell you
better than its something
last longer than that well wait what was
that just oh i got i got the case of the
adhds what were you just saying
what were you oh no what are you just
saying i'm saying that you you're saying
most people don't use their their types
wholeheartedly you buy go to the store
you buy your you buy your container or
your thing of phil you cut tubby cream
cheese and buy a brand new mayo you are
definitely finishing the cream cheese
before the match it's just only if
you're just the numbers oh i agree with
it
if you eat tons of bagels no the
servings in a mayo is way more than the
servings in a cream cheese and it's not
tons of bagels because if i have cream
cheese in the house i'm gonna have it
once every week you know or something
like that once every week you've got a
10-day shelf life that's it nah nah it's
not i have it all the time
well then you're playing with fire
whenever i have a bagel i'm always like
i have to say am i feeling butter or
cream cheese today it's as
i i have it as much as butter if not
more
on bagels i'm not i i'll get it i've
never i'll tell you this one right now
ready i've never finished a mayo
before i went back that's right you're
buying too big of a mayo or you just
don't like it you get your costs
you you you you finish your menu you run
out of money when you look and it's
still i i have to have this right to
restock mayonnaise because i run out of
it yes really i buy a but here's the
thing i buy an appropriate jar
if i buy do you think i bought what do
you think i bought maybe you're buying
them by the ones where you're buying the
people
we will buy this one we were little the
glass big ones yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh my miracle whip or whatever it
was called imagine going through that i
think in the 80s like people use way
more mayo because they were selling the
jars like this big
like really glass jars like that yeah
you put a knife and it would go all the
way in yeah and it was huge in the end
you wouldn't buy that much
could somebody who's like families
it's for that but i will say this i
don't do them anymore but i used to eat
a lot of bagels i would eat a lot of
bagels so like if you had cream cheese
on your bagel i could see they're going
faster than the mayo i do crackers in it
oh gross
gross the grossest uses for cream cheese
crackers
cream cheese and celery when people do
that that's disgusting
it's so
gross but you love everything that cream
cheese contributes to i you love
cheesecake you love it it's one of the
main ingredients
i actually like cheesecake as well i
mean red velvet icing that's like i
don't like eggs but i like mayonnaise
you know what i mean like you know it's
like
yeah no i i like a cream cheese icing
what's crazy is that but it doesn't
taste like cream cheese when you go to
look at me i want to come back to this
policeman because i like it but can you
go to mayo ingredients when you go to
the mayo ingredients it's weird because
the ingredients alone nothing's gross
about them
i don't think right right it's like is
it like uh what is it eggs
so mayo ingredients
uh eggs oil an acid of vinegar and lemon
juice it doesn't like it's not like oh
god but when you combine them something
about me it was gross well it says
emulsifying whatever that is that's the
gross major emulsified is is is
definitely the variable what's the
emulsifying mean again i don't know i
think you're just like cooking aren't
you like the is it has to do with the
fat right i think yeah i think you're
like rendering it almost or something
what was emulsifying me
we're just doing like hey what are all
these words me
uh
make into or become an emotion
[Laughter]
so you put those ingredients you just
mix that together and that's mayo you
don't have to do anything to it
why is nobody making home homemade mayo
then no
really yeah it's miracle
no
miracle
sandwich bread that may have been
mayonnaise-based but no it has a flavor
there's like a dressing a cheaper
alternative to mayo it contains the same
ingredients but less oil uh
sugar water sugar and spices oh wow so
what is the contender to hellmann's
if not miracle whip helmets and heinz
make some mayonnaise and those are
that's it you know i'll tell you one
place for green
dukes duke's craft craft
whole foods
yeah but oh wait
miracle whip is number one
yeah
number six oh it's just naming them yeah
hellman's is
what about oh i think one place that
cream cheese wins by themselves if you
take a spoon into both those jars i
would rather take a spoon into a cream
cheese jar than actually than a mayo
joint
a spoonful of mayo makes me want to
throw up when i was younger my friend
his family ate mayonnaise sandwiches
on potato bread they were just just mayo
on bread and there's some great
depression type [ __ ] oh it is it is
that's not great i wouldn't do it that's
not gross
i think it is manny's
soaking a bit into bread tastes
delicious oh even that sense gives me
the heebs the whole thing gets heavy
dude come on you gotta roll the the
weight that mayonnaise like
oh stop stop it
but i think if you had to if you had to
take a spoon into one of those i would
run for the cream cheese i would
immediately thank you sir i wouldn't
mind that oh yeah right oh my god what
about that remember when we were younger
and there was that life scare and school
lice and they used to check your hair
with the pencil erasers and send kids
home because it was lice and outbreak
where i was from we had that yeah they
said you had to go home and
shampoo your wash your head with mayo
yes i remember that iced tea
put a video on his instagram was there a
reason for it
i don't know where he like got it from
he wasn't his video it was the video he
posted on his instagram of a kid
with where he goes the barber and they
find lice
and
it's haunts me to this day
it's so gross
i want you to see it almost was it his
kid no no it's just a it's like a video
he it's not his video he's just oh
you're sharing it okay
oh my god
look
oh my god god i wish i didn't see that
oh i wish i didn't see that it looks
like a magic guy oh my god this kid's
sitting there and the guy he's like yo
dude i need to videotape your head i put
it on my tick tock oh my god
doesn't turn into like worms like that
big ones dude
that kid those things were like said i
don't even want to keep watching it it's
oh god that is i just that's like maggot
size like that's insane i've never seen
it i don't think lice turn into that
though is what i'm saying i feel like
that's something else
i don't know what else it would be
so gross god that's that's untreated
lice like normally you hop on it and
shave your head
that's the one you dispense yourself
uh of course mcdonald's comes into play
mcdonald's just don't support he needs
to pay us
i don't support this video or approve of
it it says gross video shows maggots and
mcdonald's sauce dispenser i don't
support this i don't approve of it you
know oh oh god i can't i can't oh
that's the spout that's the spot oh god
i will never use that again i will never
use that
i will never ever ever ever i use it at
wendy's they have it i'm like oh it's
fun because i can control my ketchup and
you can't tell me how much ketchup i
won't do it again you know
it stands it stands for reason
it's like they say don't drink out of a
brita in a hotel because they don't
clean the pipes yeah it's we don't know
what they're doing
in the fridge in there we don't know
what's in there oh this is a
i hope so i hope so
i didn't even know i could ha ha like
that's how how long is that if i can't i
can't even look at it anymore that takes
that takes like weeks right like that
takes a long time for that to happen
watch this i watch this alone and
thought of the rosa
why because he goes to mcdonald's all
the time
by the way i want proof that that's
mcdonald's i'm not seeing any making
these signs
show me
uh we got a company uk
it was in the uk wasn't even here he
wants proof
[Music]
why would you want why would you want
the statistic of proof it doesn't make
any difference what do you mean why
would you want someone to prove
something statistically no show me that
it's in a mcdonald's you want proof this
could be a sauce dispenser anywhere sure
but you want to go but you'll accept the
proof that you get
sometimes you're not
you accept proof sometimes you won't
it's okay you're saying a picture you're
saying a video
showing that they're in a mcdonald's is
the same thing it's the claim
yeah
no i'm saying you want proof like and
then you said the pepsi challenge wasn't
proof
yes
do it wait here's the thing i think
previous challenge was an advertising
campaign was it not yes
i want to do a couple things here i want
to read um i want to read these nine
things we should know about mayo okay i
want to i want to know how much
hellmann's makes a year and how much
philadelphia cream cheese makes a year i
just wanted to well who are you going to
say is more
because they're the only game in town
but they're almost all the creatures
honestly hellmann's is really the only
game in town everybody else is just a
barnacle yeah or a magnet so hellman
says makes 401 million a year it looked
like in sales
oh boy oh boy hello
hello fresh don't love to cook but when
i'm doing it hello fresh is the only
time i cook all right with hellofresh
you get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep skip
the trips to the grocery store count on
hellofresh to keep making home cooking
easy fun and affordable and that's why
it is you know it america's number one
meal kit okay now more than ever we're
looking for ways to save some money
hellofresh is 25 less expensive than
takeout and even cheaper than grocery
store shopping enjoy the freshest
flavors okay every single hellofresh
recipe includes ripe just pick produce
that travels from farm to your door in
less than a week that's a hf guarantee
okay it's not just for dinners they have
breakfast wholesome snacks desserts
you'll find everything you need to
satisfy your cravings without stepping
foot into the grocery store or the mini
minimart it helps they work with your
schedule plans are flexible you can
change your meal preferences update your
delivery days you can even change your
address just taps on the app it cannot
be easier okay you're someone who
starved for time if you're someone who
likes to cook but doesn't have time to
go grocery shopping if you're someone
that wants to learn how to cook all
these things if you're someone with a
family that needs quick options once in
a while hello fresh checks all those
boxes
um
go to hellofresh.com tastebuds six five
and use the code tastebuds six five for
sixty five percent off plus free
shipping that's big go to hellofresh.com
tastebud65 and use the code tastebuds
six five when you're checking out for 65
off plus free shipping hello fresh
america's number 1
uh
four how much
hold on that seems like a third of the
total 1.3 billion market out there so
hellman's makes up a third of all
mayonnaise
dude did you see that heinz ketchup is a
distant third to hellman's mayonnaise
that is nuts wow that's how much people
like man wait so go back to that how
much is that
one
400.2 million in a year
philadelphia
499 million that's what i'm saying
they're the only game in town
yeah like it's weighing in all the
creams that's a bill
way less complicated can i tell you can
i just say something
scallion cream cheese gross vegetable
cream cheese disgusting blueberry cream
cheese gross i'm just my point is that
there's a cream cheese out there for
everybody whipped cream cheese there's
this
even even in stores now they have that
many varieties of creatures but if
you're from new york and you go to
something a bagel store is a hallmark of
new york it's like a bodega okay and you
go in there and any good bagel store
worth their assault has about 10
uh like artisanal like the homemade
uh cream cheeses and i love that i love
the varieties notice about those cream
cheeses
every one of them is full because nobody
has that
look we got olive
it on cream have you tried the hot
pepper cream cheese no no there's
anybody else
put the regular [ __ ] on there and go
easy on it because i want to taste the
bagel it's gross now here's what
happened there right i said something
that was factual
and then joe said something that was
editorial you understand the difference
what was factual about what you said
without a doubt you said any bagels to
work they're sold as ten creeps true
okay you know that yeah okay and you
said and none of them are sold and then
and i made a joke and i did a little
acting
comedy work
what i'm saying is but we're here to
debate bro
and what i'm telling you is a lot of
times you come back on against facts
with your opinion and i'm telling you i
disagree with your opinion that every
good bagel service has 10 cream cheeses
in it that's an opinion and what i'm
saying is is when in my experience when
i go into these bagels that have a
variety that variety is not anywhere
near as touched as the regular cream
cheese now did i exaggerate for the sake
of colorful entertainment in a [ __ ]
podcast yeah you want to sit here and
read out of an encyclopedia we can do
that i would love to do that pepsi
challenge
i should have a cream cheese challenge
mayo
nine things you should probably know
about mayonnaise mayonnaise can be made
with nothing more than oil egg yolks and
lemon juice or vinegar when it's
homemade it hardly resembles
store-bought kind at all i wonder what
it resembles
i there's yeah there's something that
happens in the processing of it
barack obama that's it mayonnaise and
he's not alone that's got to be a
preservative thing that's another thing
that's crazy like there's probably
insane you want to talk sorry no i'm
just saying insane preservatives in the
in the mail that's why it gets it's got
to be part of the taste but this guy's
this guy's bragging about goofy cream
cheese flavors
mayo is responsible as the basis for
ranch for blue cheese dressing for
thousand island dressing
i don't like any of those thousand
island dressing there wouldn't be a
jewish deli in existence without
thousand island dressing
i'm going to start doing what twitter
did to trump to you why is that not true
that is the number
take them off the box
he said why is it not true i'll tell you
why you said it wouldn't be a jewish
deli in existence again without ground
dressing i'm just saying a colorful
thing but joe you can't just argue with
a big who you rainbow right you can't
just be colorful okay any i'll say the
way you would say it any jewish delhi
with their soul
will have thousand island dressing in it
okay there you're happy i said it the
way you would say brown mustard and
thousand island dressing are huge
staples that is an opinion and that i
would have accepted that okay but you
said i talk the way i talk i'm sorry man
it's like an idiot but i talk the way i
talk like a master
sorry many of our favorite condiments
are made with amazing buddy aioli aioli
come on tartar fancy
mayonnaise i don't like tartar sauce i
don't like these things all right you
want me to tell you okay you don't have
to it's mine i don't commonly i'm saying
mayo's got you beat in the versatility
department if you want to talk about
branching out and being the basis for
all these other things like you do with
cream cheese i'm saying mayo cake
sing it has your beat
i'm saying it as you beat if you want to
bring versatility to the argument mayo
has your thing beat i'm sorry it does
carrot cake
it's most commonly believed that
mayonnaise was invented in 1756 by a
french chef
store-bought mayonnaise is said to be a
good remedy for head lice at the very
least it can work
you know
that you know how that's how bad mayo is
it's like
it will lice can't stand the mail it's
like the how coke so bad for you that if
you put it down the drain it cleans out
your pipes yes same kind of thing yeah
it takes nice oh you have you have a
a home-grown bug infestation in your
flesh mayonnaise will take care of that
hellman started out as a popular
condiment at a new york times
in your hair not yours richard oh blue
ribbon by the way it lives in your hair
not in your flesh
i just want to stick to the fact hair is
part of your flesh i want to stick to
the face hair is coming from your flesh
i want to stick to the face
is your hair connected to your flesh
it's not flesh flushing my flesh blood
on my blood we're all made in jesus
images not jesus no we're not you know
what's a good point that you can say
about mayo is that where is that missing
link why is homemade mayo an atrocity
and what's that missing
chemicals do to get it to the
tangible great question
thank you for coming
it's like anything that's processed i've
made my own ketchup before it just
doesn't taste the same
[Music]
what's the recipe
partially i was laughing at that and
portia was living how hard he was left
i imagine you're alone no it's like
vinegar tomato paste salt it's like and
you have to
you have to you have to boil it it's a
pain in the ass and it doesn't taste the
same it just shut up kensington yeah but
that's why kensington ketchup tastes a
little weird honestly because it's
delicious it's it's it's okay it's the
best ketchup
what is kensington ketchup
shut up sir
is better than heinz i said okay okay
all right yeah all right but what
inspired you to make your own ketchup
because i was trying to try it i was i
was i was on a diet
he's lonely
yeah okay
sit at home alone and you'll be making
fun of everything
ketchup the epitome of happiness he's
eating a bagel with half a pound of
cream cheese on it every morning if
that's not waking up with depression i
don't know what is all right
joey's so lonely he makes
through he's homemade going through
bricks of cream cheese
he's eating his feelings
yeah that i do joey's so lonely he he
meddles
with homemade condiments
he's there's so much there's so much
else to do and he's like let me try to
make my own guy
no honestly i did it because honestly
here's where i did it because you
mentioned sir kensington on the show
yeah i love them and i was like i want
ketchup but i don't want it to have
sugar in it so i looked up red like i
tried to find a brand that didn't even
how did it taste you couldn't it it's
probably one of those things you got to
do a lot of it to get to where you need
to get it
i did it by the book it's not that hard
to do it it was it was annoying enough
that i didn't want to do it again and it
tastes fine but it's
th these things when you do them at home
there's just something not
yeah i can't explain it but i think but
do you have restaurants now well the
thing is they make their own ketchup so
ketchup's a little bit different but for
some reason mayo
there's something wrong
with ketchup can i make a quick appeal
something's just i don't know what it is
but would you mind if i made a very
quick appeal to camera
sir kensington and i have us a little
bit of a relationship
they heard that i i'm a fan they sent me
some product i really liked it at one
point it came through through my
team that sir kensington
mentioned maybe me developing some type
of condiment with them
uh
and i thought that i didn't realize that
they had done it before but i later
found out they did one with chrissy
teigen and it's a french fry sauce which
is really good actually and i just want
to put this out there to our fans if you
cause i really would love to make extra
kentington flavor
if you could tag sir kensington on
instagram on you know on on on twitter
wherever you want to take and and tell
them listen
get back to me i'd like to follow
through that i would love to make a
flavor i'd appreciate it i think you
should make it in derosa's honor
yeah i will i will name it after derosa
do you i'll tell you what it would be
cool
if you do make a
salvage
sir kendington's joe de rosa
we should put
what are we doing sir kensington we have
uh i i i i mean an iconic new york spot
right now it's making its way in the
lower east side it's a gritty upstart
from my friend right here that is
getting reviewed on all this side with
the shot you know that right
i think is that a show
[Music]
i want to hear you guys yell at each
other again
honestly joey rose is if you're watching
sir kenzie we know that you are joey
roses oh someone clipped this and sent
it to him joey rose's has been getting
written up in every single food blog
social media eaters shout outs to eater
we were just an eater they're raving
about his sandwiches as they should be
not only the the delicious but they're
an amazing price in this day and age and
they instantly became a classic in the
neighborhood and if we make uh you know
a sandwich together we can
we can do a a basically uh a bespoke
sandwich i would be into that and i was
and i i do love heinz ketchup but i was
joking if i said anything disgrace
that's okay no but we could do like a
circumstance
we could
call one of your sandwiches to
kensington yes well you know what i mean
can you call this red the light
bartender named kenzie
you have a bartender named kendrick
polish i mean it's kids oh my god this
is writing itself it's writing itself i
i actually do like ken sir kensington
ketchup
heinz is my favorite forgive me they do
an avocado-based mayonnaise or
kenzington yeah that i really actually
think is better i like i like kenzie did
but even the kensington ketchup
they're no different than anybody else
i was trying to find one that didn't
have sugar in it and that you can't and
it's got diet sugar in it it's got the
substitutes okay so you know but i will
give you this kensington they got a
great honey mustard they got a great
chocolate they they do come in with five
ingredients which is nice and
there's there's i thought kensington the
whole thing was there aren't it's all
like natural they're they aren't that's
what that's what you're saying but it
still has okay am i i'm sorry
if i'm speaking out of school
maybe it doesn't have sugar in it it
might have
pure cane i think or something something
like that i don't [ __ ] well listen
it's not keto also we do commercials
listen
this is a freebie but we also do
commercials like why don't you advertise
on the pot okay yeah it's possible to
make mayonnaise without eggs why don't
more food places advertise on this
podcast
i know
we have we have a few food sponsors but
not a ton
you'd think we'd have more food stuff um
you know i agree
we got a food podcast we got more
exercise bike ads on this thing
i don't know what it is he has nothing
to say it's facts he's not going to give
it back there mayo is a great way to add
shine to dull houseplants yeah that's a
red flag
that's a red flag
professional floor snow it just wash the
leaves with soap and water and rub a
drop of mayo on them they shine for
weeks never heard that in my life the
manager at the comedy seller asked if
they could add mayo to sal's ass
that's all
oh joey that that's the kind of thing
that worries me if you're using it for
using it for so it kills lice and it
puts a sheen on house plants i don't
think that those these are bad things
i'll tell you what it is i'll tell you
what it is about male 1 first and
foremost i'll tell you what it is it's
the smell
it's the smell if something doesn't
smell appealing to everyone all the time
like it's out it's out the window you
have to overcome the smell of mayo
i agree for me it's awesome
like someone's like you're like oh that
person smells like [ __ ] man yeah look
at this let's slide into the to the to
the phones if mayo was a person it would
be the shirtless sweaty fat guy you
always find in the modern day
that's very funny excellent very funny
uh my wife grew up so poor she ate
mayonnaise and cheese sandwiches
whenever she was hungry
uh i've never seen or heard of anything
more disgusting it's not disgusting it's
just it's a sandwich without meat that's
it
uh i know that as a trash person joe
will be defending mayonnaise because i'm
also a trash person all right thank you
wake up i'll eat ass
oh yeah i'll eat ass but i draw the line
and cream cheese
cherish is a con cherish is a wonderful
supportive super fan of ours a drop of
cream cheese gives your ass more shine
underrated used for cream cheese peanut
butter sandwich peanut butter and cream
cheese never heard of it never heard of
it cream cheese and jelly
i eat this is for the gigabytes
look at that do not try this at home i
hope you enjoy it
this [ __ ] shout out superhuman i need
both by the bucket
it's just mariah
mayonnaise doesn't even taste like
anything and yet it makes sandwiches
better cream cheese on the other hand
will send me to the pearly gates if
something is off that's a good one is
something off on cream cheese what do
you mean it's cheese salad it can go bad
both serve its own purpose the two words
resemble are the epitome of things that
go bad existence cream and cheese the
existence of mayo is a hate crime
okay
i'll agree with that mayo is disgusting
fermented eggs while cream cheese can be
into a frosting a cheesecake fillings a
plain bagel jelly everything
neither
i will use cream cheese in place of mayo
that's disgusting how does that do that
when they make those
sandwiches they put cream cheese on them
or something that's so gross that's
really good give me a thick shimmer
cream cheese on my bagel and i'm happy
if i got a shimmer of mayo on my
sandwich a war crime would be committed
i would rather drink a gallon of whale
semen than take a spoonful of mayo
being an ugly fat guy myself there's
nothing like cream cheese and yogurt on
ew
yogurt but he did write again i'll see
myself all right
cream cheese goes bad way too quickly
it's like dairy's avocado very good
there you go as a new yorker if you're
picking mayo over cream cheese you need
to leave the state that's
i i
don't like logic like that mayo want to
want to make your sandwich soggier
without adding any flavor that is true
joe you mentioned you mentioned that as
a
as a as a positive that mayo soaks into
the bread but it gets the bread soggy it
gets the bread soggy if you'd use too
much of it and if you leave the sandwich
sitting
that's what
actually and i can i actually can
factually prove that to you because you
had platters of jelly roses sandwiches
for days they did not get soggy did they
even the ones that had some mayo on them
did they get soggy but you you know how
to use it that's what i'm saying but you
can overuse it it's not an art it's like
saying that to me is like saying a burp
ketchup sucks on a burger because it
leaves stains on your shirt it's like
yeah if there's too much of it you have
to use it properly that's that's what
that's what that is that's a pitfall
well the mayonnaise smells like uh
putrified
suppose you petrified vomit in a jar
there's so many good subs there's so
many good substitutes for mayo cream
cheese cream cheese nothing compares to
it nick that is an excellent point nick
my favorite thing is people are making
jokes and then that girl emily just
writes mayonnaise is
gross
mayo is the worst thing ever created
well i see a bunch of people saying that
i was a little don't understand
they were a little too quick and they
chose what they liked better by accident
i don't understand they're both
delicious wait so wait but wait if mayo
wins both oh wait a second
this is in my favor it's the worst no
no you're saying cream cheese is worse
so if mayo has more votes i win
i'm fighting that mayo's worse i asked
which is worse which is worse let's
let's go to the vote let's go to the
vote it's about that time let's give the
let's give the winning tweet to cherish
against superfan i'll eat ass
uh but i draw the line of cream cheese
it's very funny uh sean with plugs
follow cherish at
cherish
underscore x0x0
you gotta babes okay before you vote uh
trunny uh yeah on social media i am at
shawnee time on instagram and twitter i
have a podcast called the brand new
jerks and also i have a youtube special
coming out in october if you search my
name you'll find me on youtube sean's
hysterical he's our good friend great
comic you got to watch it when it comes
out guys so mark that down and uh
support the pod please subscribe if you
don't if you guys are listening we have
a lot of listeners that's one thing
people don't realize about the pod we
have a lot of audio only listeners um
just as maybe even more than video right
which we love people don't realize that
because they think like youtube's
everything but if you are an audio only
listener and you haven't watched it uh
on video you're missing a lot of jokes a
lot of times especially between things
we do here pimps editing all that stuff
check out the pod subscribe on the no
press channel rate us on itunes that
would be a big help follow on spotify
all that stuff is the easy way if you're
a fan to help us i say it i sound like a
broken record but we used to never say
it i think it's important to say merch
is available in the link on the video or
going to either one of our websites we
both have tour dates up at savile county
comedy.com joederosainfo.com
uh yeah that's it you're going to drop
in our actual dates right earlier so
yeah so are we good yep so humble pie
segment right here now let me ask you a
question where do you think we are here
i think cream cheese is gonna
win
no win is the least favorite one yeah
mayo is gonna mayo is gonna be
considered worse and i think by far
considering these comments well as
somebody who i was the inspiration for
this is this coming from you um i will
say
i'm even i'm convinced that i like one
of them least
now more than i i've i've made my
decision as i just i hate mayo more now
and when you started you said you hated
cream cheese more i think so yeah i
thought it was convinced yeah
that's tough to take swallow that
all right here we go yeah
you know what you can't do household
chores with cream cheese
well i gotta i gotta be honest
okay so i
the winner is mayonnaise which means
it's worse which means i took a w here
okay you won yeah right but it's not as
big a margin as i thought which means to
me that it was a really good match up
because cream cheese is definitely
polarizing as well but mayo is voted as
worse with 62.4
percent versus cream cheese 37
would be given the comments when we
first started i thought it was going to
be closer
and i thought it was going to i thought
i thought it was going to be a bigger i
thought it was going to be i thought it
was like 70 30. i thought i was going to
win i mean mayonnaise half a billion
dollar a year industry i thought people
would be like come on bro you gotta have
mayo but you know there we go all right
folks
shall send us out of here i still love
you babe i love you too coming up next
october we got dead crow comedy club in
north carolina
in november i'll be going to michigan do
a bunch of shows and i've got tons of
other stuff around that stuff and after
that stuff and coming up in the new year
and all that anyway you can find all of
it at jodarossainfo.com
also if you're in new york city please
come to my bar in sandwich shop joey
roses uh all info for there is
joeyrosesnyc.com
we're open
six days a week
opening at 12 p.m every day great
sandwiches awesome hang
and lots of booze
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right